they are on store are at the present era
Nobel Prize staggerin official lougle
Ella medicine it is a great honor to
introduce the Nobel laureate in
Physiology or medicine professor William
C Campbell
your Majesties your Royal Highnesses
your excellencies ladies and gentlemen I
speak on behalf of professor - professor
Anora
and myself we wish to thank the
Karolinska Institute and the members of
its committee who found our work worthy
of this generous and conspicuous
recognition and we thank the members of
the Nobel foundation especially those
who made possible today's splendid award
ceremony and this magnificent banquet
professor - professor
amaura and I come from different lands
we speak with different tongues but we
are one in our gratitude actually we
have something else in common all three
of us have one way or another being
connected with the world of parasites
professor - and treszura Moreau work
with very important parasites but they
are very small I like something bigger
parasitic worms are a decent size worms
are something you can really get your
teeth into
parasites are not generally regarded as
being lovable when we refer to people as
parasites we are not being complimentary
we are not praising them we tend to
think that a parasite is the sort of
person who goes through a revolving door
on somebody else's push this is unfair
it's unfair to real parasites to the
innumerable and influential parasites
from the world of nature your Majesties
your Royal Highnesses your excellencies
ladies and gentlemen it is time for
parasites to get a little more respect
and it is with much respect that we end
as we began with our thanks we add
beyond that that we are grateful also to
those who made our work possible those
who made our lives possible and those
who make our lives worth living to all
of you thank you